i was in the israeli air force and
basically after you finish up the course
you go to
some unit you kind of like choose but
basically they choose you
and eventually there are developed a
missile defense system so it was more on
the tech side of it and
being a team leader
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders meet demi
ben ari co-founder and cto of panarace
demi started his military service in the
idf elite programming course in mamram
afterwards serving in office for seven
years the software unit of the iaf where
he developed a missile defense system
and was in charge of various
intelligence and security related tasks
during a service
after being a senior data engineer at
windward demi helped co-found panaras
and serves as a cto responsible for
managing the company's technical
infrastructure
responding to marketplace developments
related to third-party security and
directing the company's analyst
relations program amongst many other
things
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders hello thank
you very much michael i had the honor of
doing my first a
home covert test
yes indeed which i think just shows the
strength of the culture and the company
and and i think it's amazing so thank
you thank you very much for coming
through the experience but now that i
know that we're both safe i'm really
excited to have this conversation and
get to know you better you know we're
sitting in penary's you just announced
an incredible uh fundraising for
your third-party security company and
you've been there for five six years
it's been yeah it's almost like five and
a half years i think
kind of crazy to look back incredible
incredible okay but besides panerai's
you know i'm i don't feel like i'm
talking to a traditional cto
because the conversations we've had
leading up to this episode didn't really
revolve only around panerai's they also
revolved around you know your own
personal journey your outlook on how you
choose the people that you work with the
background you're coming from so i'd
love to get to know you better over
these 20 minutes
take me back a little bit in time you
know army preamy
who are you demi okay uh so i'm demi
like i said um i actually came here to
israel from a country called georgia not
the state in the us
and yeah and i came here when i was like
around six and a half
and um
means also like coming to a new country
and trying to get yourself like in
general around and knowing people etc so
i think it was the first initial like
interaction that i've had with different
kind of people
and it kind of went through all of my
life
in general i can say the same thing
about school high school afterwards in
the military i was in the idf like most
of the people here in israel uh in
mamaram course the elite programming
course
and basically the whole like uh i think
way path that i've had in the initial
stage of the militaries was six years
it's three mandatory years that you do
also the course and then afterwards
serving in the military and it's doing
programming like you said from the
technology background and there i was in
the israeli air force and basically
after you finish up the course you go to
some unit you kind of like choose but
basically they choose you and eventually
there are developed a missile defense
system so it was more on the tech side
of it and
being a team leader and afterwards i
asked to stay two extra years to be in a
role that kind of like takes all of that
that i've learned at the uh place that i
was at and i actually like developed a
system and
kind of like distribute that across the
whole unit so i shifted to a team that
actually gave services around open
source and java to around like 250
developers wow
and doing a lot of projects that i
wanted to do as a team lead and also as
a tech lead and never had the chance to
actually get to that especially when you
don't have time and you need to manage
people and do different kinds of things
so i developed a
training
system to the unit itself that actually
like went on afterwards and
i think
six or seven years after i was also
kind of left the military and started
working
in the industry i learned that my
initial course the the base course that
i did in the military came to my unit
actually took the training sessions that
i've created and took that to the basic
course again it's like
yeah and it was kind of nice and also
during the military
my
kind of like intent was
uh to be able to work with the best
people possible okay like everybody
everybody wants to work among great
people and that's the way to achieve the
greatest goals in your life at least in
my like perspective
and uh it's it's a hard thing to
actually achieve in the military because
eventually people end up there because
they have to right okay they're great
amazing people really smart people but
still you have x amount of time that you
serve in the military and then basically
you leave
so one of my greatest passions were
actually to create a place that you come
to work in the morning and you actually
enjoy doing all the things that you're
creating together with great people
that's why i wanted to found the company
amazing now when i look today at the
landscape and i would and ask a lot of
founders why would you want to build a
company and so i i think that there's
two main answers that i hear and yours
is not one of those two
one answer is probably you know it's
very lucrative there's a very very big
potential upside i'm seeing people make
billions of dollars and we both know
that that's very very unlikely scenario
and if you want to make more money you
should go work for somebody else like
you mentioned yeah and the other one is
that you get to solve a problem that
you're so deeply passionate about that
you can't sleep at night yeah you're
telling me that there's this third
vertical that you're looking at which is
actually it's all about soothing the
people that you want to work with and
the people that are surrounding you in
the day-to-day yes and i highly agree
with that with practically everything
that i do in my life because i learn
from all of the people that actually
surround me okay since day one i think
that it started from my parents up until
today with my partners all of the people
that we actually hired to be a part of
our journey
and i think this is the most important
part also let's look on the
entrepreneurial i would say community
here in israel which is amazing again
because people love to help
and once you do the
the the smallest outreach to anybody
i i would say that 95 of the people
would immediately respond being helpful
okay and being really communicative and
helping you out with practically
everything that you would like so
because of that taking the chance of
actually learning from all the people
around you
is vital to actually create something
that is great and again you locked on
product technology all of that
surrounding around also making money
it's around all the people demi is doing
practically nothing at banner is okay
all the other people that we have here
with us in the company they are doing
everything okay and us
creating that infrastructure of people
to hire more people and bring on to this
journey more people
this is i think the key success factor i
would say to any like successful product
company and even sales take me back to
the
founding of panera race yeah
as you're thinking to yourself on your
priorities you're you're going you're
taking on the role of chief technology
officer and leading the r d team
in a company that is very deep
technology and r a focus
what are the types of people that you're
looking at you're saying these are the
types of people that i want to work with
so what what what conviction leads you
to what what are the types of
personalities that you're looking to
create in this family okay cool so
i will go a step back only one step back
when i left the military
i traveled with my wife it was great and
then i came back and started working at
what i thought was a small company okay
i started working in a company called
windward and why again because i knew
that i was lacking from my military
service
some aspect of the business side of it
okay because again we're all product
people r d people like from 8200 or
offic the unit that i also served at in
the israeli air force and we're really
involved of building things but
we're
managing like virtual money because this
is eventually somebody else's budget
right and once you go again to the
i would say commercial industry and
actually try to sell something
this is a skill set that we're lacking
and i said i need to go to a smaller
company to actually learn that
and then i would be able to actually
found my own company so the small
company is the one that you found
yourself yes and it was quite small but
not too small again looking back it was
kind of different but i learned a lot
right and then
after a year and a half which i was
involved again mostly in the technology
side of it okay i wasn't the salesperson
or anything like that so
then i had an understanding that if i
want to actually found my own company
the next best thing to learn would be to
actually do that okay
and a great opportunity actually came up
going back to what we said people
i knew matan and mail and my two
co-founders the ceo and the ceo
for right now i know them more than 16
years i would say wow from the israeli
air force so it boils down to
connections wow you can say that about
your also like service knowing all of
the people yeah all your surroundings is
one of the best benefits that you can
take from your military service
and
that's it this is the first choice that
you need to do about people partners
right
because eventually the idea although it
haven't changed much
will change okay usually
the product will change you will add
more functionality to that your customer
base will change what won't change is
the essence of the company that you're
forming starts off with the founders
with the people actually that start off
with the idea yeah everything will pivot
things will change it will grow the
company if it's successful and i wish
everybody that but eventually it boils
down to the people that you formed that
right and then the next cycle
the next circle i would say of of people
that you will hire
it will be the core team okay
all of the engineers that we're speaking
about the first sales people your like
eventually future management maybe or
maybe like tech
leadership
and these are the people that will form
the company with you know why because
they will build the second circle and
the third circle because eventually when
you grow and this is again something
that i've learned
you can't control that continuously okay
and the people that you hire and the
circles that you build again this will
be in your company and outside your
company with all the business business
relationships that you form
this is what will be the success or the
failure of your company now when you're
talking about people in your community
what where
where is the importance is it in the way
that you're running projects together is
it in the water fountain conversations
is it in the
you know the the slack messages and the
and the culture that you're building
there you know
where do you distill it to
um i would say the annoying answer would
be everything okay because eventually
the interaction that you form the time
that you spend with the people and what
you learn from them and learn about
yourself
this is the best way to be able to
understand all of the verticals that
you've mentioned like in technology when
you do different kinds of projects with
people it takes time it's not as a
one-off that you do a hackathon of a day
and that's it you understand that the
person that you're speaking with is a
genius you need to know that working
with him the same thing that would be in
the r d team
is pleasant and that you can he could
work also as or she can work also as a
team team member because eventually the
team creates the achievements and all of
the goals that you want to achieve as a
company and if you don't have that it
will be much harder to understand that
let's look on the business opportunity
side we spoke about the communities or
maybe even like groups inside your
company but what about outside
again the interactions that we've had
okay all of the things that our friends
and our like external circles these
types of interactions and communication
create opportunities right and
eventually once you
be you will be able to take advantage of
these opportunities everything will grow
you will make mistakes like everybody
okay but you will succeed more because
basically you try right and eventually
when you end up with this kind of
infrastructure of people
okay people to consult with i would say
even other peer entrepreneurs
okay or even when you're speaking about
the startup industry etc
investors people look at investors as
money right you want to raise money but
your goal is not to raise money is to
build a company
it's another i would say tool to be able
to do whatever you want to achieve and i
look and all of the vcs investors as as
i don't know guidance people that
actually seen a lot of companies
i i don't always like want to raise
money from them i want to learn from
their experience and i think that most
people should actually do so to to be
able to i would say scale themselves
right
looking back at these five six years of
panerai's yes
what surprised you you know you said you
you're gonna build a company you know um
one of the main motivators is to be able
to work with the best people that
that you can that you can find around
you and from your network but what
surprises you along this journey because
you're taking on a pretty significant
role the co-founder and cto yes so
i would say it's a surprise but looking
back it's not really a surprise the
amount of things that we were able to
achieve only because of the connections
with all of the people that we've had
both in
technology and also in the world of like
doing actual sales and selling the
product and
creating value for our customers
is from the people again that i've
interacted in the past i would start
from the first initial investments in
the company for every like funding round
that all the people that we know as
founders and people
are kind of connected okay
distribution channels and marketing all
of that and creating a pipeline of
customers people you know
again if you want to create a pipeline
that is unknown is again through people
that you know that were able to do that
in different companies and eventually it
boils down to everything has a
connection i would even say a deal that
kind of like was closed i don't know
like two years ago if you look back on
the trail of what led to that deal
was around
four different interactions that we've
had a person that used to serve with us
that eventually ended up of me trying to
hire them and then afterwards when they
said no they connected me to their ciso
yada all these kind of things are like
an aggregate of all the things that you
create as a baseline as a person and
that's why it's really important for me
also as a person to create these kind of
interactions even not for myself for my
friends doing developer communities
right okay so so i was just about to ask
how do you cultivate
that that motivation to form these
meaningful connections because you never
know
when they'll be relevant both on a on an
emotional level but also on a
professional level i agree so if you're
doing that
as a motivation to basically do business
it won't be as natural right okay i
really like doing that i like talking to
people i like helping people if i could
do that as a day job and not worry about
money i would literally do that from
morning to dust but basically eventually
uh all of the interactions that we're
doing especially in the developer
community this is something that i like
i like speaking in front of people
because even specifically i started from
the world of technology and then also
started doing that in the
entrepreneurial world i would give the
examples okay i started doing that in
the military it's a pretty confined
community and ecosystem and
it gets you up up until a certain point
because it's eventually like interacting
with different units in the military
when i left the military i founded a
couple of developer communities by
myself because again sharing knowledge
is something that i like okay it's
giving lectures doing things talks tech
talks again why because this is the best
stage that you can give for yourself to
get feedback right especially in israel
where people are straightforward and
they're really like blunt honest and
they will tell you why are you doing the
wrong thing and what you should be doing
and this is invaluable i think you can
learn a lot from that and i founded the
developer community to focus on big data
data science and devops
it's called big things i think we're
over like 6 500 people right now doing a
lot of like monthly meetups et cetera
cove it came everything became virtual
as you know and also google asked me to
found another community called gdg cloud
the google developer group of cloud i
really like that so it's not something
that i do
to create business but it's something
that i love to do like what you're doing
with the podcast which is amazing
yeah and eventually creating another
distribution channel and also mail and
myself my other co-founder the ceo we
founded the offic alumni association
okay
much like the
8200 alumni association which comes to
to help in the entrepreneurial and tech
world to all of the alumni and again
it's a great way to make connections to
do the mingling that you would like to
do to create business opportunities
incredible and that feeds itself i love
it
take me back to your childhood a little
bit yeah
you know what what's sparkly curiosity
are you an engineer you know by trade
from elementary school or were there
other things that you know that you were
just curious about the world yeah i i
really love coding okay something i i
really miss i must say and but we
achieved a certain point in the company
that i'm doing
some like
other things
but starting what actually like
taking back to the childhood i like
taking things apart okay if it's toys or
relationships or conversations like
literally dismantling things to know how
things tick and it helps me to to do the
next steps of trying to understand
different kinds of people
and maybe even create these interactions
that we're speaking about because then
once you understand what motivates
people
you will be able to leverage this
ability much better to find and find the
connection actually of and why are they
doing all of the other things that
they're doing i love it and if you look
today
there you go
i feel like breaking your office no no
worries if you look today at panerai's
or personal life or the relationships of
your building you know where do you gain
your inspiration you know to come and
meet me here at eight o'clock in the
morning and then go on to a full day
full of energy running this company
boils down to people okay again like i
said it started off with my parents
which inspired me to do kind of things
a lot of things in the world of
interaction and being like communicative
to people
it goes on to my wife and my two year
old daughter also and all the people
that surround us eventually it boils
down to people doing things
and
most of the people actually that know me
will know that this is the the way that
i always leverage all of the abilities
of my friends okay and the friends and
the people that we choose also to
surround ourselves with
are our essence also you choose the
friends the people that you want to
interact on the day-to-day basis with
you to again to be
the good feeling that will help you to
create new things incredible and if you
have to choose a few words to describe
yourself yeah or if i would ask anybody
here who's them i i actually
didn't know how to answer that i i went
on to asking my wife
i love that yes and and she will be able
to actually like say that in the most
straightforward way of describing myself
in three words and but it's like i just
wrote it down just just to be precise
so
it boils down to
social
um
it's
decisive and warm okay and i think it
kind of like assembles the the whole way
of thinking
and i agreed with her highly because
she's much smarter than me
and eventually it boils down to all of
the interactions that we're creating and
i i can see that from like when i look
at myself from the side
that this is again what drives me and
what makes me tick and what makes me
like to come in the morning like you
said to interact with all the people
that i think can
and and eventually create good things
with them
thank you very much for inspiration
thank you for welcoming me to your
beautiful offices and i can't wait to
see what happens with panerai but even
more importantly i'm just excited to
continue forming this relationship and
then
and being a part of the community and
getting the inspiration for how
important it is having the right people
around you so thank you thank you very
much and i would like to also thank you
of creating this thing because this is
amazing this goes to the mantra of like
distributing good so keep on going there
thank you very much